let's begin with one of them more
straightforward ones can someone tell me
is 10 plus 3 equal to 3 plus 10 yeah
[ __ ] okay so you've given me a
reasonable ready I think we're saying
it's true so I don't like that and
there's lots of different ways to say
this so the first way that being said
this was she actually just calculated
both sides okay so if you did this if
your reason looks something like this
and this they're cool that's valid
reasoning that provides me an argument
for why well if they're both 13 and
they're both equal did anyone do it a
different way oh yeah the killed shado
it's addition is comfy yeah very good if
you didn't write that and a lot of
people have different reasons if you
didn't write that I'd like you to right
now I'm going to write it I think this
is great it's true clearly but as an
idea as a principal no printer power
like mr. Johnson but a principal a
concept this is really powerful because
now if i change the question to be like
say instead of tens maybe I wrote nines
okay this black reason the width reason
to kill game is still true but if I had
to do this I'd have to rework it out
after re work it out every single time
so I really like that we could say this
and it applies all the time it's kind of
what ultras without right applies
overall numbers let's have a look at
Part B so I want to give me a suggestion
yes
okay so we'll go false and I who agrees
with that yes okay we've got a lot of
good thinking hands down okay so thumbs
up now the reason we've got is you look
at the left hand side are you yeah so
this does look a little bit weird
because if i said to you all right i
have 8 whiteboard markers can you take
away 15 of them you'd say you can't take
away 15 because by the time you take
away in the first eight there are not
left right so that does look a bit weird
have a week sports of the last herb that
helps us is a straight to her ok so you
you've gone to the next thing which is
similar to what the keel said right
which is it reversed though because I
can't reverse the order but this is like
why where do I suggest ok very good so
the word we're looking for here is that
you're going to get a negative number on
the left you remember negative numbers
and positive numbers their partners be a
family of numbers such a good wine in
remember yeah it is just very good ok so
we actually care it tells me we do we
actually can subtract 15 for me we just
get a negative number we've gotten a lot
less than 0 however it's not the same
time you get over here d what do you get
when he's 15 take away 8 yes it's seven
and so this guy is positive okay so
we're getting different things on both
sides so that's why it's false or
totally as to mention and if you haven't
written this down maybe you would
increase as well you can say subtraction
is not commutative you can't just go
around switching the order if you like
it's not like addition ok let's move
forward a little bit have a look at this
guy now again just like we have here
there are some different laws in
operation here that we can use so again
Mr Justice Odessa said anything yet I
don't do suggestions mmm so it'll be huh
that's it here addition that's allowed
cuz even
you put the brackets even if you like
sushi brackets around anytime it's
Saturday you already got your turn do
you remember or do does anyone remember
what the name oval yeah okay very good
so we're looking at the commutator vol
up here this is a math p in fact I all
of the both of these questions are about
the associative vault which which
numbers can I associate a group together
this works right it works of how many
people actually just did the calculation
people yeah okay Frank very good hands
down so you have had 12 times 8 which is
what is project it's 96 and then he have
four times 24 which is still by six so
that's why we can say this is true okay
but another is I'll go right at this
time cuz you're going to probably get
sick of you saying this is
multiplication happy gone through here
right x times x times and multiplication
is associative so that's why you could
redo this okay how about party Chris
you're in shape for this one here ok so
i bided answer for this one yeah Nicki
otezla force ok can we try to pack this
if you didn't get out to this question
can we try and do this together what's
your ask you to go about this yeah is
five months 2-6 fibers
3-6 and sigma3 the next question by the
minus negative 4 would be negative 90
he's very good with the five most a
default but what happens with those two
negatives because there's like a
switching switching direction here right
yes later it becomes positive right it's
like take away Jimmy but was looking it
up right and what you're doing is you're
taking away something that's weighing
you down so that's why the net effect
the total result is you go up that's why
I got to know okay so these two clearly
different I it's false but just like I
said multiplication is associative what
I could say here is what's the operation
here what's in between all my toes it's
in subtraction and subtraction is not
associated you can't just group them
however you like things break down as
you just say okay all right we'll go
through a litle bit quicker a part ii
again it is true what law is that starts
with adi we looked at on Tuesday someone
else yeah it's the distributive law
because you could see this three times
right multiplication by three it gets
distributed to everyone very generous
guy okay so he goes distributed to the
two and then he gets distributed to the
six okay so that's why you get three out
of 23 lots of six and whatever that
happens to me okay that's true pile it
high def will you reckon ate it okay
it's false but this is a bit funny is it
funny because hold on a second it's
still multiplication didn't we just say
multiplication is distributive like a
distributes out so why isn't this true
yeah I Delilah scene ah very good so
this time seven it gets distribute to
the six so actually this parts okay yeah
but this is the part that breaks down
you notice that cuz look you goes to the
six just fine but here he doesn't just
go to a one he goes to up by this one do
you see that so how would I changes to
make a crowd
I'm going to adjust the sign right it
really should be subtraction and then it
would be sure okay all right last one
last one what do you think true or false
so how can we work this out yeah you
guys have had some s afraid you might
suggest it's false I agree if it's false
the question is why why why yeah okay so
we we can talk about cubby 22 bitty as a
bat for certain times mask but i'm not
actually changing your order here so
like I'm swapping two things around like
I was here and here so you're right
division isn't commutated but that's not
really what's going on here to a detour
to suggest something else yeah it's
about of this 24 / doesn't go across to
all our other numbers hello ah let me
get
you can just leave it there or the
Florida great thing okay sorry true you
just mentioned that divisions got
distributive we can prove this to
ourselves really quickly what's 24
divided by two that's 12 what's 24 / 38
so this left-hand side is 12 plus 8
which is 20 but then when you look over
here what does this mean this is 24/5
now 24/5 it's going to be some funny
pics to rule but I can tell you what it
it's definitely not going to be 20 right
this is much too big so clearly this is
wrong does that make sense so you can
settle it for yourself by do the
calculation or you can think about the
principal both those are great reasons
for it okay